so we're starting today with one of the
biggest stories of the weekend and one
that has led to all sorts of different
conspiracy theorizing even involving yes
the new owner of Twitter Elon Musk and
we will get to that but let's start with
what took place a horrible home invasion
involving a hammer attack on Nancy
Pelosi's husband Paul Pelosi in their
San Francisco home this was a trumpist
anti-vax anti-semite there is no doubt
about it no matter how much the right
immediately said we don't know anything
about the politics of this guy and then
when it became clear that it was one of
these conspiracy right-wingers that they
must be lies or the entire thing was
staged or whatever the case may be so
let's talk it through step by step the
accused Pelosi attacker spread Q Anon
and other far-right bigoted conspiracies
this is an individual
who broke into Nancy Pelosi's house was
reportedly yelling where's Nancy
ultimately in the middle of the night
attacked Nancy Pelosi's husband with a
hammer requiring him to go into
emergency surgery a horrible horrible
situation and the individual uh as is
written about by the LA Times in some
detail was in the world the far-right
conspiracies anti-Semitism hate and more
in a personal blog that he maintained he
included topics like the hollow hoax a
term used by Holocaust deniers he wrote
about it's okay to be white
he mentioned the far-right message board
for Chan he posted conspiracies about
covet vaccines and even the war in
Ukraine being a ploy for Jewish people
to buy land this is all extensively
documented by the LA Times he included
posts about Q Anon
he wrote that either Q is Trump himself
or Q is the Deep State moles within
Trump's Circle
the daughter of the individual told the
times her father wrote this stuff she
said they were reeling from the news
that he had been the guy arrested in
connection with the attack on Paul
Pelosi the motive has not been
officially revealed but it has now been
learned in addition to the fact that the
guy was walking around yelling where's
Nancy where is Nancy it appears very
clear that he was targeting Nancy Pelosi
there is another article from CBS News
suspect in Paul Pelosi attack had list
of targets law enforcement sources say
um they have not gone so far as to call
it a hit list but authorities believe
the suspect may have been planning to
Target others arraignment is expected
tomorrow authorities are taking their
time fighting federal charges because he
is indeed in custody
um the suspect planned to keep Paul
Pelosi tied up until Nancy Pelosi got
home
it is not a random act as is being
reported Nancy Pelosi was in Washington
DC at the time the alleged attacker was
in the house when Paul Pelosi was able
to dial 9-1-1 and police were indeed
dispatched the suspect was apprehended
will be charged with attempted homicide
assault with a deadly weapon elder abuse
burglary and many additional felonies so
what the fundamental thing to understand
here and this is you know
it's one when something like this
happens you will often see the side
I don't even want to say that when
attackers in these circumstances are
right Wingers you will often see right
Wingers come out and sort of condemn all
violence generically
and the problem with that is that it
ignores that there has been a concerted
effort here by the right to dismiss and
normalize and sometimes even encourage
violence you know the culture of
violence promoted by Donald Trump
encouraging people to rough up
protesters at rallies dating back five
six years saying he'll cover the legal
fees of those who beat up protesters at
rallies violent rhetoric of you know
knock them out knock them around this
type of thing not ever truly denouncing
violence that is uniquely right-wing you
know the vague condemnations of listen
I'm against violence and also the
January 6 protesters were completely
right to be there and protesting because
the election was stolen from them you're
not really discouraging violence when
you do that so all of those different
things
play a role in this and when you see the
normalization of violence from everybody
from Steve Bannon recently saying fauci
and his family are going to be hunted to
even candidates even Marjorie Taylor
green is uh on audio visual recording
talking about going after Nancy Pelosi
this is exactly what happens this is the
stochastic terrorism that I've been
talking to you about for so so long
Trump has four rallies coming up
I believe it's Thursday Saturday Sunday
Monday or something like that leading up
to the election
does Trump defend this guy or does he at
least minimize what this guy did to some
degree or does he play into the
conspiracy theories that we're starting
to see about I think it's about a 50 50
shot and the magats have been
threatening Nancy Pelosi for so long
um uh to to some degree uh saying that
it is logical that something like this
would happen because of all of the
horrible communist things that Nancy
Pelosi has done which he hasn't by the
way and you end up with this attacker
who is a trump supporter watched him
pool red Ben Shapiro liked what Kanye
was saying about the Jews subscribes to
Q Anon and on and on and on this is
expected this is what I and others have
been sounding the alarm about for so
long and how does how does Fox News and
right-wing media react
a combination of depravity and
conspiracy theories let's talk about
that next
after a right-wing anti-semitic
anti-vaxx Q Anon Trump is nut
broken to Nancy Pelosi's house and hit
her husband over the head with a hammer
Fox News uh anchor Jesse Waters said
listen a lot of people get hit with
hammers
and if they hadn't defunded the police
in San Francisco which didn't happen
maybe this wouldn't have taken place
it's unbelievable but this is what
they're going with take a listen to this
what I want is that I want this alleged
perpetrator to be treated the exact same
way if he had treated if he had attacked
anybody else because a lot of people get
hit with hammers what a lot of people
get attacked and a lot of the times
they're out on bail the next day and
it's a simple assault charge so I don't
know why this guy is being treated
differently and he's facing what
attempted homicide he's in prison right
now we've seen people assault people all
the time randomly with all kinds of
weapons and we see them released the
next day not not super tough on crime
when it's trumpist rioters on January
6th or a middle of the night home
invasion these are the types of home
invasions that the Wright loves to say
this is when you just shoot them with
your self-defense gun they love talking
about home invasions and yet now he's
like well the guy's actually being
treated potentially too harshly too
harshly usually you say these people can
be shot I don't know why this guy is
getting all of a sudden special
treatment or different treatment because
the victim was so high profile remember
if you call on a welfare check the left
wants to send a social worker what if a
social worker had come to this call he
would had it dead
husband and you would have had a dead
social worker yeah I have not seen nor
have I suggested that social workers be
sent out to middle of the night home
invasions where their targeted attacks I
I have never said that I've not heard
people on the left side that say that I
have heard hey you know if you have
a homeless person where police are
called because they're sleeping on a
business stoop maybe then you send a
social worker maybe if you have you know
some kind of minor drug situation but
anyway they have to they have no choice
but to put up these Straw Men in order
to tear them down now you have to hand
it to them on the one hand they spent a
week when the Fox News Christmas tree
was vandalized no victims no individual
victims and a week they spend on that
and now it's listen a lot of people get
hit with hammers a lot of people get hit
with hammers it is truly unbelievable
and then also saying this is because of
the defunding of police there has been
almost no defunding of police anywhere
in the country
and the police department budget in San
Francisco is up more than four percent
since 2019. Waters and others love to
say they've defunded the police that's
why this is happening but they've not
defunded the police and it has nothing
to do with it actually the Hammers thing
reminds me of the good liars remember
our friends the good liars went to the
NRA convention and this this guy they
talked to tried to talk about Hammers
and it went South very quickly or people
and more crime is committed and more
people are killed with hammers every
year than guns look at the packs I will
look that up I don't think that's true
actually it's true in the United States
though sir that is true look it up it's
on you can Google it it's true it's
actually true
so the number of murder victims and the
weapons used okay number one
handguns
8029 number two Firearms type not stated
4863 number three knives are cutting
instruments personal weapons fists feet
uh then rifles
at 4 55 then blunt objects clubs hammers
uh
393. the the 300 the Hammers that that
stat is just wrong back to your question
Second Amendment is still my right and
it's still important to me yeah
everything I said was wrong about the
Hammers but I still want my guns and
then one more clip here check out how
Fox News covers the attack
and manages to completely omit the
entire political backstory of the
individual the fact that he's a Maga nut
Q Anon anti-semite Kanye loving
now police have not stated a motive for
this attack the suspect in this case de
Pepe is reportedly from the Bay Area
from Berkeley Fox digital reports that
this suspect has ties to a radical
nudist activist and has a disturbing
online presence that involves the online
presence is disturbing posts about
pedophiles Big Brother censorship and
anti-semitic content and lawmakers on
swiftly condemned this attack on Pelosi
yesterday former vice president Mike
Pence says this suspect should be
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law now yeah what a completely Anodyne
way to State listen this is a radical
and everybody condemned it it's like
hold on a second the right Wingers
generically condemn it while completely
ignoring the basis politically for what
this guy did and what his beliefs were
and it is of course deliberate that they
are doing that so not an altogether
shocking response from the right let's
go to one more little chapter on this
related to the new Twitter owner Elon
Musk in response to the home invasion
attack on Nancy Pelosi's husband Paul
Pelosi
Elon Musk fresh off of buying Twitter
tweeted a Bonkers conspiracy theory from
the Santa Monica Observer a paper a
publication which previously reported
that Hillary Clinton died before the
2016 election and a body double was
debating Donald Trump
uh Elon Musk tweeted such a conspiracy
theory uh that claims or suggests that
the home Invader was actually Paul
Pelosi's gay lover
completely baseless and ultimately
deleted that this is the owner of
Twitter that did this article about this
on CBS News Elon Musk tweets and deletes
link to article pushing unfounded
conspiracy theory about Paul Pelosi
attack and it reads Elon Musk Sunday
tweeted and deleted a link to an article
pushing an unfounded conspiracy theory
about the attack on Paul Pelosi the
tweet from musk who now owns Twitter
raised concerns about the type of
content that will be allowed on social
media on the social media site under his
control yeah that's an understatement in
a since deleted tweet responding to
Hillary Clinton musk wrote there is a
tiny possibility there might be more to
this story than meets the eye with a
link to a story from the right wing
website Santa Monica Observer a site
that has pushed anti-lgbt conspiracy
theory regarding the attack according to
an archived version of the story The
Outlet previously made false claims
including that Hillary Clinton died on 9
11 and was replaced by a look-alike you
can still find an archive of the story
that was posted and
um the story says it doesn't add up
people on social media are questioning
the attack on Paul Pelosi and it says
you know San Francisco's gay bars close
at 2 A.M and what happened was the bars
closed Paul Pelosi went home with his
lover and it was a lover's quarrel a
lover's quarrel now Ben Collins on MSNBC
C explains how this entire thing got
going and it really is instructive in
terms of how this nonsense starts with a
spark and very quickly becomes a fire
that is difficult to put out first of
all lies on the earth move faster than
the truth and that's in part why there
are all these safeguards that Elon Musk
is trying to take down on Twitter right
now
um the lies that were pushed were from
Bad pieces of information they found for
example they said that uh Paul Pelosi
was uh in his underwear of course he was
2 30 in the morning at the time he was
attacked they that led them to believe
this was a lover's quarrel between two
different people that knew each other
the reason they believed they knew each
other is because the police put out a
statement saying that they didn't really
know who opened the door so they that
led them to believe there was a third
person in the house
so from there there was this World
building on the pro-trump internet what
could be the opposite of reality here
and the opposite reality they came up
with was these two people were having a
lover's quarrel in a house and the
police sort of intruded on us it's
fundamentally incorrect it was pushed by
the richest man in the world and then
yesterday it was pushed by Donald Trump
Jr who posted a picture of underwear and
a hammer and said it's a Halloween
costume for Papa Lucy
if we don't cut this out right now not
just the normalization of violence but
the idea that reality can't even exist
anymore because it cannot catch up to
the lies on the internet
I'm not a scholar on authoritarian
history but I've let I've read Hannah
Wright I've read all of these people
this is how it gets really bad
this is the start of something that gets
really really bad yeah and Ben Collins
is of course completely correct and the
added layer to it now is forget about
whether Elon Musk is going to properly
moderate at Twitter the dissemination of
outrageous disinformation he's
participating in spreading it which is a
new dystopian layer altogether let me
know what you think find me on Twitter
and remember if you are watching our
content on YouTube and you are not
subscribed
what on Earth are you thinking no in all
seriousness our YouTube channel is on
its way to 2 million subscribers we
found out
that there are millions of YouTube
viewers who watch our content every
month and don't subscribe make sure to
hit that subscribe button it does so
much for us it is the most important
indicator to YouTube Hey should we
recommend David Pacman's content or Not
So speaking specifically to those of you
who watch the clips but that subscribe
button is enabled because you're not
currently subscribed do us a favor and
hit that button we'll be at 2 million
subscribers before you know it we will
take a quick break and be back right
after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
remember that the David pakman show is a
viewer and listener supported program we
do an extra show every single day for
our members called the bonus show oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
but everybody else that makes money to
find themselves as bad consider
yourselves invited to sign up at
joinpakman.com would love to have you uh
you can use the coupon code big voting22
through election day then that coupon
code goes away big voting 22 to get
yourself a discount Brazil is going left
lunatic president jair bolsonaro has
lost in a relatively close race to
left-wing Lula who is returning to the
presidency in Brazil it is a major
International political story we're
going to talk about all of it the
guardian reporting Lula triumphs over
far right incumbent bolsonaro in
stunning comeback remember that this was
the runoff election because no can that
it got 50 percent in the initial
election it was scheduled for October
30th indeed it took place not
surprisingly many on the American right
Steve Bannon and others already starting
to say it was rigged it was rigged it
was rigged we've seen this story before
it's the same story but in Portuguese we
are not going to fall for it uh the
guardian reporting Lula stages
astonishing comeback Brazil's former
leftist president Lula has sealed an
astonishing political comeback beating
the far-right incumbent jair bolsonaro
in one of the most significant and
bruising elections in the country's
history with 99 of the votes counted
Silva a former Silva Lula de Silva right
Lula a former factory worker who became
Brazil's first working class president
20 years ago secured 50.8 percent of the
vote and indeed the results now have
been further counted to 100 percent the
results are Lula 50.9 percent
enjoy your bolsonaro 49.1
um many right Wingers focusing on the
5.7 million invalid or null votes to say
no it was stolen from bolsonaro uh we
will have a deeper dive into those
numbers uh maybe tomorrow or the day
after now I know that many of you are
going to write in and say David it's
hard to imagine given your skepticism of
corrupt left-wing Latin American leaders
that you would be a big fan of Lula now
I think it's important to say many
people don't consider Brazil part of
Latin America this is a different
conversation not for today but to the
extent that we are talking about South
America it is true I'm not even a fan of
Lula but it is of course way better than
bolsonaro now here let's talk about this
and by the way let me just put out there
right now
the people who love to write in or post
on Reddit
davidpakman is a uh the the son of Rich
argentinians who supported the military
dictatorship and that's why they left
with money from Argentina that that's
the opposite story okay my parents were
and are left-wing argentinians we lost
folks we knew during the military
dictatorship we left to get away from
the right wing insanity and the
destruction of the economy not with its
support so anytime you see comments like
that about me you should ask what
evidence do you have to support that so
that's not the reason for my skepticism
of folks like Lula now remember I'm
going to say it again were I choosing
between bolsonaro and Lula I would of
course vote for Lula but what are the
reasons I'm not the biggest fan of Lula
well it's a very similar package to
other self-serving
South American Central American Latin
American left-wing leaders we've seen
the the the routine in Argentina we've
certainly seen the routine in Venezuela
plagued with corruption scandals charged
in multiple of these Affairs you can uh
just to pick one I mean there's like a
dozen of these check out the men's allow
Scandal this was a major parliamentary
vote buying Scandal by Lula's original
Administration
um he gave in to the horrible Venezuela
style calls to have government
controlling media in 2004 Lula pushed
for the creation of the federal Council
of journalists as well as a national
Cinema agency this is this is when these
left-wing leaders do the Venezuela stuff
we've seen it to some degree in
Argentina as well I'm anti-authoritarian
so I can't support that stuff operation
Car Wash where Lula was accused of
influence peddling and lobbied for
government contracts for specific
foreign specific companies and foreign
countries this would be like Trump or
Biden going to Germany and saying listen
I would really like for you to hire
Exxon in your country it's overt
corruption we would denounce it
wholeheartedly I would anyway as a
progressive no matter who did it uh he
persuaded the Brazilian Development Bank
to finance specific projects in Ghana
and Angola and Cuba and the Dominican
Republic this is corruption this is
cronyism this is the stuff we hate I
could give you the full list there's
like seven eight different scandals here
and Lula along with his former Chief of
Staff Gilberto Carvalho and five others
were indicted in a corruption probe as
part of operation zelotes which uh
involved the payment of bribes so sadly
Central South and Latin America have
been plagued with these corrupt
left-wing leaders and the sad thing is
that you end up with all kind of bad
choices look at Argentina when it was
you know more Christina or right-wing
mockery these are not good choices and
the entire continent
has been plagued with it would I support
Lula over bolsonaro yes I would uh but
the idea that this is some kind of
Panacea very much not the case Joe Rogan
and Dr Phil have been spreading the fake
news story of fentanyl candy it is
Halloween so it seems like an
appropriate day to do the story this is
one that has become very popular Donald
Trump has been spreading it at his
rallies others have been repeating it
drug dealers are going to poison and
kill your kids by disguising fentanyl as
candy sadly uh it is not true but it is
still being repeated take a look at this
those pills look exactly like the pills
that you get at the pharmacy and what
they're doing now Joe is they're putting
them in these pastel colors uh and I
think I sent you some of those Jamie uh
in the pastel colors they're making them
look like these candies that the kids
get
um and kids are going to see these
things around and pick them up and think
they're like
Sweet Tarts or or whatever and bite into
them
um
if if I was a parent
I would go to the store and buy every
kind of candy I could find and as soon
as my kids came home from
trick-or-treating I would take their
pumpkin and dump it into the trash and
then fill it back up with candy I knew
was good and hand it back to them I
wouldn't let them take a single piece of
candy from trick-or-treating because you
don't know what's in there
that was always the fear right when we
were kids so someone was going to sneak
in we thought he would be a razor blade
in an apple or something yeah I saw this
going around but I heard a lot of people
pushing back a couple days after this
yeah Jamie rightly suspects that this
may not be a real story made major
headlines because they were showing them
say no who's the expert I don't I'm just
it there was a lot of uh hubbub about
this viral picture because this went out
the D.A was talking about it but then I
read there was like no evidence that
this was real exactly that's what I read
well let's scroll down and see what they
say in terms of looks like candy DEA
administrator Alan or Ann uh Milgram
told CBS News in fact some of the drug
traffickers have nicknamed It Sweet
Tarts Skittles the DEA alert didn't
mention Halloween but fears about
rainbow Fentanyl and the holiday went
viral
DEA warning meets skepticism from drug
experts drug policy experts contacted by
NPR agree there's no new fentanyl threat
this Halloween many are also skeptical
of the dea's original warning right I
don't believe that Mexican drug cartels
and Street dealers have launched any new
campaign targeting children I don't see
any evidence that the DEA has produced
that supports that conjecture
I don't think they're targeting children
I think the fact that they are making
these things in pastel colors make
children vulnerable to but Dr Phil you
just said they're going to hand these
out at Halloween and you've got to swap
your kids candy
picking these things up yeah you you
want to argue over the the word
targeting
well there's a lot implicit in that word
if a child picks up something where how
that
look you know on the floor drug dealers
are going to leave fentanyl on the on
the ground I said that young girl that I
was talking about took three quarters of
a pill or one quarter of a pill and
three quarters of it was left in her
drawer yeah if she has a a younger
sister right a very specific
hypothetical so let's break this down
why do right-wingers love this story
it's a way to attack Joe Biden that's
that's the origin of this story and you
might say David how on Earth does
fentanyl candy serve as a way to attack
Joe Biden here's how they do it there's
fentanyl in candy
which came in through the Border which
was opened by Joe Biden so fentanyl
candy is Biden's fault and he hates kids
who are going to be poisoned by fentanyl
as they pronounce it uh which is
um uh part of how he doesn't care about
kids now you would think that Rogan
would realize this is the exact same
thing as with the Cannabis Edibles there
was a time as we saw more states
legalize cannabis recreationally
where people say you know a lot of these
Edibles just look like a chocolate bar
it's a very very dangerous kids aren't
going to know they're just going to say
hey chocolate this is good next thing
you know they'll be high as a kite I'm
guessing Rogan rejected that then
because it made no sense but he is not
really applying the same skepticism here
although good for him for at least
looking up an article first of all this
doesn't pass the sniff test the idea
that drug dealers would just dish out
free drugs either as a goof during
trick-or-treating or just would leave
drugs around when the whole point is to
sell the drugs for money doesn't make
any sense drug dealers want to make
money there's no Financial benefit to
dishing out fentanyl laced candy to
Children which might kill them what how
are you making money from that it
doesn't make any sense whatsoever now if
you do some Googling you will find some
stories of drug dealers using candy
packaging
and putting drugs in there and you can
get a resealing machine to make it look
like the Skittles package or whatever
was never open but they're they're not
doing this to then hand out at Halloween
they're just trying to do this to get it
through the Border or authorities or
whatever where police would see it and
say oh it just looks like a package of
Skittles is it hypothetically
theoretically possible that your Skittle
bag that has actually been emptied and
refilled with some kind of drug and then
sealed it could be misplaced and end up
in the hands of a kid sure that's
theoretically possible that's not new I
hate to break it to you but if you
Google what do ecstasy pills look like
MDMA
for decades they have looked like candy
they've got heart-shaped ones and
they've got this that it is not new and
it is not a real thing that kids are
just going oh crazy Sweet Tarts put them
in my mouth
it's a fake story and understand that
the origin is to criticize Biden about
the Border we'll have the clip I played
on our Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show former
president Barack Obama was out
campaigning for a number of different
2022 candidates he was in Georgia he was
in Michigan he was elsewhere as well I
believe and I have to tell you that it
was extraordinarily refreshing now I
know some of you will say hell but David
you neo-liberal liberal shill Barack
Obama used drone Warfare and I would be
with you a hundred percent and I was
critical of that when it was going on
but generally speaking Barack Obama made
clear that there was one party right now
that believes in democracy period no
matter what the outcome is whereas the
other party the Republican Party sort of
believes in it if they win but if not
then they believe in something very
different than democracy he spoke
passionately he absolutely crushed all
of the Republicans uh that were running
in those States and I don't want to
waste any time let's get right into the
first clip here is Barack Obama on
Social Security this was in Milwaukee
Wisconsin campaigning against Ron
Johnson for Mandela Barnes a very
important race
some of you here are on Social Security
some of your parents are on Social
Security
some of your grandparents are on Social
Security you know why they have social
security because they worked for it
they worked hard jobs for it
they had checked hands for it
they had long hours
and sore backs and bad knees to get that
Social Security and if Ron Johnson does
not understand that
if he understands giving tax breaks for
private planes more than he understands
making sure that seniors who've worked
all their lives are able to retire with
dignity and respect
he's not the person who's thinking about
you and knows you and sees you and he
should not be your senator from
Wisconsin
every single one of this weekend's
speeches was this level of energy and
also this accurate about what it is that
these Republicans want to do here's
another brilliant one from Detroit
Michigan
the other day I I did not realize this I
did not I've read about this somebody
had to show it to me the other day a
video came out of Governor whitmer's
opponent claiming that Democrats have
been working for decades to topple
the United States because they're still
upset about losing the Civil War
Coleman restrictions were part of some
master plan to do this now
first of all
what
what what
I mean I know some folks go down these
rabbit holes on the internet they're up
too late
but that that's like a Subway tunnel
that that's that's deep
and that is indeed the way it works they
go down absolutely Bonkers conspiracy
theories now then he was also in Georgia
in support of Raphael Warnock against
Herschel Walker where by the way the
polling is looking increasingly
disastrous for Raphael Warnock but we'll
cover that momentarily uh and Barack
Obama making the case Herschel Walker
fine football player but Senator that
doesn't make any sense some of you may
not remember
but Herschel Walker was a heck of a
football player
I mean I mean some of you are too young
to remember but in college he was
amazing one of the best
running backs of all time
but but here's the question
does that make him the best person to
represent you in the USA
does that make him equipped
to
weigh in on the critical decisions
about our economy and our foreign policy
and our future
let's do a thought experiment
let's say you're at the airport
and you see
Mr Walker you say hey there's Herschel
Walker Heisman winner let's have him fly
the plane
[Applause]
[Music]
you probably wouldn't say that no you
would not and indeed saying that he
should be one of 100 members of the
Senate making such important decisions
is insanity and sadly that's what's
going on Barack Obama making the point
that House Republicans are ready and
willing to impeach Joe Biden they don't
even really know why a record if they
get control of Congress they will spend
the next two years
investigating
President Biden and their political
opponents that's all they want to do
they see it as payback
and some some of them said that they
they're they've already got prepared
that they're going to impeach you uh by
they're not sure what for
but apparently that's beside the point
and you're laughing except
they've actually said that
they have literally said we're not sure
what the theory is but we're going to
come up with one in fact there's an
incredible clip from I believe it was a
New Hampshire debate which I played for
you where they were going around saying
what would you impeach Joe Biden for and
everybody agreed they should impeach
Biden other than one candidate but they
disagreed as to why they should impeach
him and they have absolutely no idea in
reality Barack Obama also making the
point that no matter what's going on out
there even an asteroid heading towards
Earth they want tax cuts for the rich
and they do
[Applause]
actual solution to it
well no I'll tell you
they want a gut Social Security
and Medicare and then give some more tax
breaks to the wealthy
and the reason the reason I know that's
their agendas listen that's their answer
to everything
when inflation is low what do you want
to do cut taxes
when unemployment's higher what do you
want let's cut taxes on the wealthy
that's going to solve that I was joking
down in Georgia if there was an asteroid
headed towards Earth
is gonna land in like two weeks
if you went in the Republican caucus and
you said what do you want to do
well we need a tax break for the wealthy
that's going to help
I'm I'm only barely exaggerated I don't
even know that he is exaggerating I
think if there were such an asteroid
Republicans would say well let's I guess
do something about the asteroid but
let's remember once we survive the
asteroid we need to encourage business
growth and the way to do that is give a
tax cut to the rich I don't think it's
an exaggeration whatsoever Barack Obama
accurately pointing out that there are
two obsessions for Republicans right now
owning the libs and getting Donald
Trump's approval this hasn't always been
a partisan thing
my favorite President was a guy from my
home state of Illinois named Abe Lincoln
helped found the Republican Party
it used to be that there were GOP
members who championed progress and
civil rights and rule of law
folks who who were with me in the 2008
election you remember right we we talked
about bringing people together and and
and spoke to all people regardless of
party about how we could move the
country forward
so so that's my instinct
I I I'm not
some buddy who believes
that all that some party label defines
this
but I but I I have to speak the truth
which is these days
just about every Republican politician
seems obsessed with just two things
on the lips
yeah let's open the lips
and and getting Donald Trump's approval
that's their agenda no no no don't boom
Bo
om
yeah
um he does warn Barack Obama does
Mandela Barnes you'd better be ready
with that birth certificate my friend uh
I wanna
say something here uh
I know that there's some folks probably
maybe not in this Auditorium but
elsewhere in Wisconsin
who think and I know these ads are
running this way that
just because
Mandela's name Mandela
[Applause]
just because he's a Democrat with a with
a funny name
he must not be like you
he must not share your values
I mean we've seen this
it sounds pretty familiar doesn't it
so Mandela get ready to dig up that
birth certificate
get ready
yeah
um love him or hate him on his politics
uh former president Obama is very very
good at this now will it be enough to
turn around some of these races I wish I
could say yes let's take a look at some
of the latest polling if you want a
single poll that confirms that America
is rapidly crumbling
it is a very disturbing series of recent
polls almost all of which
have Herschel Walker leading Rafael
Warnock in Georgia
this is such an important race the
incumbent Democratic senator Rafael
Warnock is being challenged by former
football player Herschel Walker Herschel
Walker can barely speak he cannot
coherently explain his position and the
reasoning for his position on any issue
he claims to be against abortion period
but has now been caught urging multiple
women and paying for the abortions of
multiple women
and if you look at recent polls from
just the last week you have Walker
leading three of the four polls Walker
plus two Walker plus five Walker plus
three with Raphael Warnock up in one of
those polls New York Times Sienna and on
average
Herschel Walker is now leading this race
imagine the humiliation it will mean to
the United States if Herschel Walker is
one of 100 senators
all is not yet lost make sure that you
vote other races that are not looking
good the Kerry Lake Race in Arizona
where lunatic big lie conspiracy
theorist Carrie Lake who wanted to
secede from the United States at one
point although now she denies it she is
leading Katie Hobbs in all of the four
latest polls plus four plus three plus
eleven and plus two on average Kerry
lake is now leading by almost four
points Kerry Lake could be the next
governor of Arizona
Vance versus Ryan JD Vance is now
leading or is tied in every recent poll
against Democratic Challenger a
democratic Contender Tim Ryan for the
Ohio Senate another very important race
for a little while it looked like maybe
uh Ryan was going to going to be right
in there now just about every poll has
JD Vance leading I hope that if you live
in Ohio you will be voting and in
Pennsylvania Senate race Oz versus
fetterman we are still trying to figure
out what is going on but it is as close
as it has been there is now an Insider
Advantage poll that has Oz leading
although on average and sadly these
polls
predate the debate between Oz and
fetterman so we don't really know what's
going on the momentum has certainly
shifted for Oz as you can see Oz is the
red line and just climbing climbing
climbing to where it is now a veritable
tie if you look at the 538 Senate
forecast for uh who is expected to
control the Senate it is now essentially
tied
what at one point was let me take a look
what at one point was
71 percent odds that Democrats would
keep control of the Senate that has
dropped 20 points and it is now
51.49 this is the lowest point for
Democrats controlling the Senate going
all the way back to what was it The Late
July summer period
this could very quickly become a
humiliating disaster for Democrats I
hope every single one of you plans to
vote I certainly do
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
Sarah Palin is running for a House of
Representative seat representing Alaska
she's the former mayor of Wasilla the
former partial term governor of Alaska
and former vice presidential running
mate back in 2008 you might remember she
quit being governor before the end of
her term and she is essentially giving
up and if I didn't think she was such a
disaster for the country I might feel a
little bit bad for her but I don't Sarah
Palin appeared on Steve bannon's the war
room and she said there you know what
I'm no longer accepting donations I've
gotten rid of my campaign stuff staff
because they gave me bad advice let me
interpret this for you Sarah Palin has
given up she's trying to save money
because it would be pointless to keep
spending money because she's obviously
going to lose but look at the spin I
didn't know what way was up and down
after I heard this the first time I'm
gonna get in trouble for saying this but
sometimes you wonder the people who are
actually advising working on campaigns
you gotta wonder if they're really in it
for the right reasons because sometimes
they give really crappy advice and
effort so I'm doing a lot of this myself
I'm not going to ask people for
donations though which ticks off those
in my campaign who and other campaigns
you know because they look at this as a
business and they get a cut of funds
raised I don't ask people for money
because I've won all the races that I've
been in over my life except one
um the big one and uh I've done it being
outspent ten to one or whatever it is
because
he'll be outspent 10-0 now I roll and
it's always worked well
yeah and you can tell from the look on
Steve bannon's face
it's over for Sarah Palin what this
means is nobody is supporting me anymore
I'm out of money no one's donating
anyway so I'll say I'm no longer
accepting donations as we talked about
last week Republican Alaska Senator Lisa
murkowski is voting for Sarah Palin's
Democratic opponent people don't like
that Sarah Palin quit being Governor a
lot of Republicans in Alaska
don't like Sarah Palin and this is just
the last nail in the coffin I'm no
longer having any staff and I'm no
longer accepting donations you're giving
up Sarah you're giving up and my hope is
and I don't know if this will be the
case
My Hope Is that this will really be the
end of Sarah Palin's political career a
career that never really should have
gotten started but it did
um and she is really in a in a sense a
precursor to the trumpism that exists
today Palin giving up and it is yet
another humiliation Marjorie Taylor
green going from One Lunatic extremist
Republican in Sarah Palin to another
lunatic extremist Republican and
Marjorie Taylor Greene Marjorie Taylor
green says listen it's okay that I
believe things that aren't true because
lots of my followers believe things that
aren't true these are my words not hers
my guess is she would put it a little
bit differently but let's listen to what
Marjorie Taylor green had to say on this
it looks like the it looks like this
program is from the 90s night talk is
the name of the show
check this out
I think the Atlanta paper tells me about
10 days ago you were still in session at
a trump rally in Arizona that Trump was
won the 2020 election and it says if you
are one of his biggest allies
I am always proud to support president
Trump Judy I'm so grateful for the way
he led our country with his America
First policies
um I miss him very much uh being our
President and so do a lot of people and
I do I say all the time I really feel
like he won the state of Georgia and I
feel like he won the state of Georgia
now
is there a factual basis there no but
she guys she feels it and I do think he
won the 2020 election but you want to
know something it's okay for me to say
that because a lot of people feel the
same way right
this is actually super important
they justify their investigations and
their claims about the 2020 election by
saying lots of people feel this way lots
of people believe this
but the reason that lots of people feel
that way and believe it
is because people like Marjorie Taylor
green told them that it's true now I'm
not excusing anyone right it's not if
Marjorie Taylor green told me Trump won
I wouldn't believe it unless I had
actual evidence that suggested that but
it's a vicious circle this is like the
Marco Rubio Dropbox thing last week or I
think maybe it was the week before at
this point uh senator from Florida Marco
Rubio who's a republican he's running
against Val demings Val demings is a
democratic congresswoman who now is
running for Senate and one of the best
debate performances by the way was that
by Val demings but there was a certain
point when the topic of election
Integrity as they like to call it came
up were Mark or Marco Rubio said well
listen
there's two reasons why we should be
against these ballot drop boxes one
someone could bomb the ballot Dropbox
which hasn't happened and it was
interesting that he was giving people
that idea and he said the second reason
is people don't really trust the ballot
drop boxes but at the time we said well
why don't people trust the ballot
dropboxes because Marco and others are
telling them they aren't trustworthy
so is that really can you really use a
belief you created as a reason why
something should change in the way you
want it to change this is like a TR when
Trump says a lot of people are really
angry about what happened in 2020 and so
we have to look into it well they're
angry because you lied to them and made
them angry based on things that aren't
true claims that are completely debunked
and
um if you apply this I mean imagine that
Marjorie Taylor green or whoever said
listen I think Jews will not replace us
is a really important thing for us to
talk about because a lot of my
constituents feel the same way they're
worried about the Jews replacing us so I
think it's an it's a totally logical
thing to talk about we wouldn't accept
that at least many of us would not maybe
some of Marjorie Taylor Green's
followers would so understand that they
use the beliefs they created in others
to justify their continued Pursuit and
further lies about these issues it's an
endless Circle uh there's this term
docsastic closure that is sometimes used
to describe this where there's you can't
your Universe reinforces the very
beliefs you are in this is often the
case with religious beliefs and I know
that some in the audience may not like
this analogy one of the things that
often happens with religious beliefs is
people say
here's my beliefs because this is what
my sacred texts tell me to believe and
so they are true
and then you say okay what evidence do
you have that these sacred beliefs are
really sacred beliefs given by God they
say well the sacred texts themselves say
that they are sacred
and then you try to exit the bubble and
say right but what do we have from
outside of that that tells us these are
the sacred beliefs given by God
they don't have anything but it doesn't
matter the very claim within those
sacred beliefs is self-perpetuating by
virtue of saying these are the sacred
beliefs of God and you can't pierce it
but you sometimes you can but it is very
difficult to pierce it same type of
thing with this voter fraud stuff we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P here is a question from a
viewer about something former Fox News
host Bill O'Reilly recently said
hey David it's James again
um I don't know if you heard but Bill
O'Reilly recently made this prediction
that uh Joe Biden is going to announce
uh that he will resign after the
midterms
um
I I think that at the most he'll
announce that he won't run again but he
won't announce it over his dying uh just
less than two years into his uh term
um my question to you is do you think
Bill O'Reilly actually believes that or
is he lying in sort of pan right to an
audience
because he figures like his audience
would love to hear that fighting is
going to resign
or do you think that there's any truth
to that
um
I certainly don't yeah so listen what
the caller is referring to is that on
news Nation Bill O'Reilly showed up and
everything Bill O'Reilly says he says
very confidently Bill O'Reilly said that
sometime after the midterms Joe Biden is
going to announce I'm resigning the
presidency and it's because of health
reasons and Bill O'Reilly went on to say
Kamala Harris is not going to be a
viable candidate for 2024 so it's going
to leave Democrats in a difficult
position in 2024.
um listen I don't have any reason right
now to think that Joe Biden is going to
resign the thing about Bill O'Reilly is
he'll tell you whatever and he'll say it
extraordinarily confidently his
confidence should not be used to
evaluate the likelihood of the claim is
it conceivable that a president would
resign yes sometimes presidents resign
uncommon but it can happen it is a
mechanism that exists all else being
equal is it more likely that the older a
president is the more likely it is they
might resign for health reasons I think
statistically that's probably true I
think it's more likely an 80 year old
president would resign for health
reasons than a 70 year old president
than a 60 year old president then a 50
for you get the point
do I have any reason to believe that
this is part of Biden's plan not at all
and it's increasingly looking to me like
Joe Biden does want to run for
re-election in 2024 six months ago I
would not have said that but it
increasingly looks that way and I do
agree with the caller that if there's
going to be a sort of a wind down to
Biden's presidency that will not include
four more years it will be Biden saying
I'm not running for re-election is a
resignation possible of course it's
possible
um but I I don't have any particular
reason to think that's the plan we've
got a great bonus show for you today we
will talk more about Elon Musk Elon Musk
uh wasting no time after buying Twitter
in instituting some changes not all of
them particularly exciting uh secondly
men exonerated in the killing of Malcolm
X are set to receive 36 million dollars
it's an incredible case which we will
talk about and we are going to talk
about ballot measures up next Tuesday
it's it's election day next Tuesday can
you believe it measures that could
change how Americans vote
how Americans Gamble and how Americans
Vote many uh how Americans smoke rather
many changes potentially coming on
smoking gambling and voting to multiple
States we will talk about those ballot
initiatives and much more on today's
bonus show when I am joined by producer
Pat remember to get instant access to
the bonus show you go to joinpakman.com
and you sign up there's a big red sign
up button it's easy it's quick I believe
the normal prices for membership are so
reasonable but I understand sometimes a
discount is appealing you can use the
coupon code big voting 22 to get
yourself that discount and remember if
you watch us on YouTube and you're not
subscribed help us get to 2 million
subscribers it's free hit that subscribe
button I will see you on the bonus show
or otherwise we will be back tomorrow
with our one week out from the midterms
program